so you said uh mass and strength go hand
in hand just at a big level about arm
wrestling what's more important
strength
power endurance skill strategy or mental
toughness like what how do these
components all
come into play in arm wrestling
they're all important
you can use everything and you can
adjust your strategy based off of the
tools that you have
i would say if i i could
pick ever just one thing to have more of
uh
i would i would say that it would be
strength
gained
while fighting
while actually i'm wrestling not off the
off the no no so you get stronger from
arm wrestling how do you get stronger
from armrest like in jiu jitsu and
grappling you can get good by
training with people
much uh technically worse than you so
with white belts and blue belts it's
actually a beneficial degree because you
get to work stuff out right
but
i wouldn't say it develops like
that intensity and power required to go
against
people at your level so what how do you
balance that do you is it okay to go
against people that are much weaker than
you
or um that do you really have to go
against people at the same level
i think that a blended
strategy is probably the best
i i'd say kind of a rule
is whatever you do you get better at
right so
you want to be kind of as precise as
possible
you don't want to get hurt um
and it's just about investment and
the answer is not always the same
things are going to change
i am currently a big believer in what i
call tower building right so
you have to do a lot of volume
to build a great tower
you you need to have a ton
a ton of volume so so when you look at
how to best build volume
you want to do
workouts that aren't particularly
challenging to make you feel good
and do them so that when you add them
all together
you get the biggest number
so
many
easy workouts a day
that are specific as possible in my
opinion is the best way to lay the
foundation for an extreme peak and
precision right like
there's no more precise way to get
strong at arm wrestling than arm wrestle
you